[Applause]
now i i have to take
uh i take marijuana because i have um
what's that called
oh no an addiction
it was so it was so easy
i thought it was gonna be hard
like i thought they were gonna be like
does anybody have their medical card in
here
yeah okay i'll see you there um
can i tell you when i got my medical
card so
i was like okay
i figured i was gonna need
and so
i go in and i went in high
because they said you're supposed to see
your doctor with your symptoms
and i'm in the lobby right
and i'm just practicing the story in my
head
i don't know about here but there was a
poster that said if you have any of
these
incentives
he will give you your card like what's
the [ __ ]
chichi
like i can get a story i could just
so it was an applicative so i just
memorized the first stick on top i go
god
and i turn by the way does this
happen to anybody else who sent me well
if you see something you're like got it
don't got it like that right you know
what
i'm like did alzheimer's just start
right now
it's suffering you've got it got it got
it
so i i memorized that i'm like first
daddy again i sit down and they call my
name
mr rules come on
and then go to the doctor and i sit down
let's sit across from me because this
wolf
why do you feel like you need medical
marijuana as soon as he asks me the
question
what i had memorized
flew right out of my head
and he was like why do you feel like
you need medical marijuana
and i remember he was first
and i remembered it was alphabetical but
that was all i remembered so i was like
autism
and he goes just like this
he said you mean anxiety that's it i got
anxiety
super anxious i'm making autism someday
can you just [ __ ] write me the
prescription
[Music]
[Music]
but you know how the story goes another
day another dollar howler 7 pm once
again to break another 45.99